okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
incremental language development for
from language and we've got some a bunch
of different items to talk about so
first thing is geo position and
threading so this is right so the so
first we explain here why'd your
position needs to have so many lists
inside it's it's coming from the polygon
structure and then there is a proposal
for a new training function so okay so
the main issue is if I were to say
something like if I were to go ahead and
say something like geo position of
something like you know capital cities
in South America I'm just I'm just gonna
try and work this through so I'll get
that okay then this will generate that
then then what we'll get is that okay
now if I want to function to operate on
that if I say find shortest tour it
probably knows how to deal with that it
does in general if I want to see those
geo positions separately what do I have
to do right because in this case it's
just a list of positions we can use this
threat does that work I mean I would
never have thought to do that but yes
okay fine right now the problem is that
sometimes your position contains a list
of lists and then we need deeper
threading and and thread cannot do it
what why do we need wider the kernel of
the list because we have this idea of
polygons of your positions and and
polygons can take multi lists so your
position needs to take that as well so
that example of the of the US shows that
so you see that we have nearly 3000
points separating three lists so if we
thread once we get the six lists
I see so in other words the sixth
there's a sex non contiguous parts of
the US is that what you're saying
exactly yeah three independent non
overlapping polygons
but so so the internal structure of that
if I say input form a percent one here
the internal structure of that I see is
a geo position of lists exactly but in
other cases will be a deeper list and
then thread because thread can only
thread through one level it gets
complicated to threat what if normal to
in this case nothing this is a separate
discussion of whether if normal should
do something on your position and
because it could do several things it's
not so clear I mean I would have
expected it to just unravel the thing
but that one level several levels okay
let's see your proposal yeah so here for
example if we have to thread through the
two levels we need to use thread twice I
understand and then this section is a
bit of explanations of what thread does
yes and the main limitation of thread is
that it can only thread through one
level and not thread for example has a
third argument in which you can specify
how many levels you want to thread
through but it has a different structure
you have to separate first ahead and it
really requires lists if you have
something else like in this expression
with heads H doesn't work so much thread
is not the solution either here I mean
any of these things is fairly obscure to
know but okay all right so let's say
proposal for new threading phone yeah
this code is is obscure it's just I took
code of something it's just evaluated so
for example and so this comes from
another operation which is a
generalization of transpose and so this
is a di and the name is totally
tentative so here is a kind of fun and
not alliterative but it has some rhyming
character head thread okay go ahead so
so yes so here we are specifying how
many levels we want to thread through in
this case two or three yes
so in the case of geo position would it
know how many levels geo position likes
to thread to well in principle ideally
we would thread the minimal possible
because it's important to keep packing
for for fast operations so that's why we
keep the positional hell outside so
that's why I don't want to thread all
the way down and if it's possible to
specify how many then then that will be
better
now this function for which I don't have
a prototype it just decide just fake
examples is the general case of
threading in which you specify it has
four arguments and you specify the
expression the number of levels you want
to thread the function that should be
thrilling and the function it should be
threading through that's the general
case so we need F and G okay and so so
yeah so the relation with thread I think
it's in the previous subsection okay
let's talk about G opposition case yeah
how would head thread solve that your
position case well one would say Oh a
half at your position with so many
levels inside I want to thread through
how do you know how many levels you have
because it's written in the in the
summary box but that's annoying I mean
look this country happened to have
islands this country didn't happen to
have islands you know that's a very
obscure thing there is a property or so
because your position has properties one
of them is depth and it will tell you
how many levels it has in case what
about what about having a property of
your position what about solving this
problem the Geo position by having a
property of the Geo position which is
the unraveled version as well yes but
but still we need to specify how many
levels you want to run well okay so hold
on let's let's imagine let's let's take
a look at the properties of
geo-positioning let's say individual
points
something um do here of the opposition
for some of properties they're listed in
the deters are you saying this I didn't
know those existed this happening an
intron we did document them together but
they were they documented here that's
listed yet wow that's cool
well I by the way hmm okay alright so
it's I I don't this never made it into
the new and 12 list that that that
should be somebody needs to ed go edit
the new and 12 list and add this this is
so embarrassing
you know we have so much new
functionality that we keep on forgetting
to add it to our new in this version
list so I saw this in the new in 12 list
at least one of them somewhere okay well
if it is it is I didn't remember it okay
um okay but so here what I'm suggesting
is that what we would do is something
like we would have points and we would
have regions or something just like and
points would resolve all the way down to
the individual geo positions
I see so different names for the
different yes because that way um a
little bit like the way that the OSM
database is organized you know that we
have something where you say regions
okay great it'll just give you a list if
it's a single it's a country with a
single contiguous section then it'll
just give you a list of you know you get
what I'm saying
that's this seems useful to me yes we
can certainly have those properties I
still think that it would be nice to
have a more powerful threading function
because this of this need appears in
other places no I agree I agree so okay
so let's agree on
point is geo position will get these
things that say points and regions and
so on and by the way don't don't forget
like here it will be good to put in the
in the Nepalese different face yeah
right
what um that's interesting what that
works yeah so just I was in perspective
at it is I wonder what happens if I say
geo position of point five it's just it
just stays at your position yes you
could threat first and then and then do
your position and it would collect them
again okay and what is the let's take a
look I see the second argument is a
datum which is kind of a useless thing
don't other functions have datums as
options with ecology a model in other
cases yes but in what your position is
it's fundamental for the other functions
is kind of informative at the beginning
to know what they have to do I feel this
is a a grid coordinate somewhere it's
just totally different meaning than if
it's a benefits a lot long exactly in
fact the meaning of life long depends on
the data in different items the same
place will get different numbers it's
like the projection in geo grid position
it's still an argument even though
nearly most of the places it's an exact
ok if you gave a geo model here with it
will it absorb itself and become that
second argument yeah but that's a minor
thing because if I were to say at your
position here a wrapping geo position
with a new datum what would it do it
will change they will inject the datum
yes it would perform that they the
change of Satyam
oh really does it document that yes okay
alright so I hint with geo position
that's okay so let's talk about the
threading function which I which I think
nobody is ever gonna guess in the case
of geo position but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't have such a threading function
alright so let's take a look at your
general case reading function all right
yep so it's an expression let's look at
thread first this thread is a very old
function yes
Scholarship hasn't been modified since
version 1 it has the weight in history
opponent um the okay seen in a sense the
modification of threat is math threat
you see that's a very similar thing in a
more powerful way but still not fully
you know
alright so thread in general has a head
specification which is your which one of
these G its G okay but this thread has a
takes back here that you don't have in
the case of head thread here exactly
yeah I don't find it that useful but yes
it's true that that's a difference I
think it is sometimes useful but I think
it's a different use than that some of
these other things exactly and it's in
fact why I'm not suggesting to
generalize threat but to have a
different function to about confusing
the two ends okay so let's take a look
at what you're proposing here so most
important thing is the fact that you can
thread several arguments because the
function thread can only thread one you
mean by several arguments
you mean that possible levels so for
example in the first example their head
threat
is pushed to levels deeper yes I
understand
do you believe in the name had thread
not really ideally this will be thread
itself but if we add another argument
yeah it's going to become a 5 argument
thing which is you know so different
yeah well I mean thread is perfectly
useful in um it is and it's occasionally
used with its second argument and I have
seen it used with its third argument so
I don't think we should knock and thread
especially but I think the ok so you're
saying I don't quite understand ok so
that first thing says ok so you're
taking the outermost head and you're
pushing it a certain number of levels
down right it's right ok so if I were to
do this if I would say that comma list
list why no didn't get preferred for not
okay but so if I would put a bit more
encrusting here would that work ok so
let me understand what this did so this
is a tree this is pushing that function
down in this tree right so if I were to
look at this as a tree
you know we should consider making tree
form more beautiful is this business
about it saying list all the time it's
just really ugly I wonder if there's a
better way to do that I mean I wonder if
we should have a way just a better
visual way to indicate this I kind of
think I'd neuron that functions have
solved this to some extent can we can we
ask the the neuron that visualization
folk what whether they've done well
they've got a partial solution to this I
mean I think the main issue here is that
that node is just way too heavy saying
list not agree I mean I mean so you're
thinking like braces with the
placeholder in it or something or maybe
maybe something like that so just
something more lightweight because it's
just so heavy and it's so you know it's
it's talking about a structure that well
anyway I just think that that's some
okay see um okay so okay so that's what
we did them we transformed one of those
to that so it's an operation that pushes
a function down into a structure and the
structure should be a somewhat
conforming it has to perform at least up
to that level in other words if that
level didn't exist we wouldn't be able
to push it down right if the function
has several arguments the arguments need
to have the same head and the same
length that happens already in front you
see that thread its main function is to
thread across arguments this function
you are proposing if you think the one
argument form you know F of one argument
is going to be a useful form that's a
slightly different way of thinking about
it
yes I'm thinking of the particular case
I mean the general function I'm
proposing should also be able to handle
several arguments like thread das but
also working one argument right in the
tree opposition case what would you
actually do if you want to get let's say
you have the US and you want to get the
points in the u.s. you would say head
thread of that geo position comma to
that correct right and for example
imagine that did your position had a
datum then we would have to replicate
the datum and all the internal your
positions
yeah that that's why we need to also
worry about the head we are threading
through because it has to be list that
happens already in threat so this H in
the second argument is telling us thread
through the objects with head h and
consider the rest as scalars
fine so in this case you're saying you
would promote the level argument to the
second argument and I mean it's not
thread all is it no it isn't thread all
I mean I generally like the idea of this
function okay so that it would default
to head to list being the head the head
you thread through but I also want to
specify the head
I want to thread I agree I agree which
is the H thread F here over any objects
that occur so you're specifying what
that F is because that F might be if I'm
understanding correctly that F might be
at a deeper level exactly for example
the operation of thread cannot be
inverted because once you have pushed F
deeper now how do you how do you bring
it back so you are imagining a negative
thread that swings it back exactly so
those are the examples there you specify
the head you want to push and how many
levels and in the general case through
which functions you want to push it
right so let's talk about how we agree
with this function I think this function
is a fine function to have um how on
earth do we name it um how should we
think about it I mean so it is in the
family you see threading I always view
as being a corresponding a threading
corresponding things through yes that's
the role of F and that's why map thread
has that name yeah but map thread for
example doesn't have the G freedom and
so if you put things with heads other
than lists in the second argument of map
thread doesn't work and this has been a
generalization that has been requested
in the past
so in other words an argument so you're
saying that this would then have the the
argument structure would be n here and
then the F is in a different place from
the way it is in head thread because it
means something different but then
you're saying a comma H there off to the
N that represents what you are no I'm
very confused that that says the second
argument forget about it having lists in
it it's okay if it has H's in it right
so if it's obvious which one's for
example imagine of the expression 1
expression 2 hat head H then matter
doesn't work it would say is we consider
that they are scalars so it cannot
thread through we throw oh hold on hold
on if I say H of the list of H of 1 to H
of 2 3
okay right so these could have returned
H of F 1 to F of 2 sir
it was a bad example it's tends to the
second 2/3 to 3/4
okay the why doesn't that work the the
outer most list is just a container it's
not going to be reproducing the result
so the other most least is kind of
irrelevant the ones that are important
okay so you're saying in your H F ID
form yeah that you would expect that
result to be H of F of 1 to F of 2 3 is
that right right
yes but sorry I think we should use 3/4
in the second because otherwise we are
getting confused why does it make a
difference because it we are getting the
same result back and it should be
exactly so not clear
oh I see okay so then this is 1 3 2 4
where that is now I say it's now
applying the H and curly if we had
deeper levels we would have nested HS is
that true or not yes and it well that
seems like a reasonable generalization
of map thread but Sandra our live stream
is suggestions read down as a possible
name rethread I'm not getting that I'm
not really getting the thread idea here
because the threading as far as I'm
concerned is you take multiple objects
and you are threading a function through
those multiple objects I mean I would
say the quintessential thread case is
something like you know thread in F of
you know a b c d or something i mean
it's the list ability it's it's just
we're just implementing the stability
susan indeed
um and okay so the question here is what
is the operation that is pushing that
down in the tree hmm how to think about
what it's doing
I just don't think it's threading I
think it's it's some it's some kind of
destruction will be a generalization of
threat in a sense so it will also be
able to handle several arguments and
then it will be a two three yeah I
understand
well there's there's weird possibilities
like thread inside because what this
does the difference from thread
initially is that this is capable of
doing sort of multi thread so to speak
yeah I mean in other words it can do it
can do a threading that is down at that
level in a sense this is also a bit like
inner in the sense that it has the same
FG functions so inner eyes red deep
thread in what way is that like you know
it has also the freedom of F and G and
in fact I'm trying I'm always trying to
be consistent in the naming of F and G
and many of our functions have F G
freedoms and they mean the same thing F
is always a threading function that
takes multiple arguments and so it's a
bit like x and G is like list or plus
the function that collects at the end
right and it's like the Map Reduce story
right so yes so here you see the
different about their relation with the
previous case that we were discussing
yes that is interesting do we do we make
it clear that that's yeah we do
so a few meetings ago we discussed this
generalized function I have called are a
contract threat which is kind of the
super general concept of threading and
all of these other functions thread
inner mat Fred dot outer and this one as
well put the particular cases can we see
that function can you remind me what
that function looked like does it have a
what parameters does it have it's
implemented in the symbolic stencils
context and it's called documentation
for it no I don't have the commentation
but I can give you an example if you
want okay
symbolic turn source a trade contract
FET and then it takes the F function
then a list of a race so let's say yes
ABCD and now the list of constructions
which would be like list list 1 1 and
then G committing all symbolic tenses
okay
so this function has five arguments it
has the F function the list of arrays
the list of constructions in the
notation of tensor contract the G
function to collect them like in ER and
then a fifth argument which is the what
I call the effective depths
it means goes down go down in their race
up to this level like outer thus
remember the number character about her
yes
so here it's a list of of numbers rather
than Burrard so it's a fifth argument
but it's the same idea the idea that you
are dealing with a race and you say no
treat them as a race only up to the
level and how widely so tell us a
contract takes a single tensor
what does contracted is it by default it
adds what what happens if I want a
different operation than adding the
circuit racket is there is the
mathematical version of this which can
be symbolic as well can stay they are
waiting for other operation so it only
supports F equal x and G effortless do
symbolic operations worth the time
coming in it's a it's like outer so in
the same way that tensor product is the
x version of outer yes so tensor
contract again it's like inner
generalized to many arrays and and any
depth but it only supports plus
sometimes I hope it doesn't have an
application section from like the women
tensor or something yes yes I could tell
examples we good I think but okay but so
this this function the function is
saying you take the two there there that
array there and contract the second
level and the third level of the array
right and if you have many you can what
needs to be done is to first have the
tensor product of that in activated if
needed to avoid the intermediate as well
right someone's asking on live stream
why then functions without documentation
because these aren't real functions yet
these are just experiments right there
in internet contexts there that's what
we want to do is make them to the point
where we think the design is right and
we can go ahead and document them
okay so we've got so are you saying that
thread inside or whatever it's called is
a special case where a contract thread
yes but it's simpler to understand which
is simpler to understand
dead head thread thread inside okay so
in what sense is contraction how does
contraction relate to flattening they
are independent operations contraction
the general idea of contraction is that
of having an array with multiple indices
and doing something two pairs of indices
whereas flattening takes for example
pairs of indices and unravels into a
single index I mean what flatten is
doing is to take something that might
have two indices and unraveling it so it
just has one index right whereas what
you're doing here is to take those two
indices and you're getting rid of one of
those indices by knitting the things
together using you know multiplication
and addition right engineer construction
gives you smaller things and I guess
that's the origin of the word
construction we're flattening is the
same size but just you've rearranged
right so if we compare the flatten of
that and now can we do a contract of
that tons of contract yes you would have
to say levels one and two because it's
only has two okay so I say one two like
this that's the trace wait a minute so
in in Einstein notation something that
will be T mu mu is that right with the
repeated index Convention for
contraction
so is it always the case only try to
understand by the way is there a
generalization of the Einstein summation
convention of I mean so the Einstein
summation convention is always pairs of
indices because we have this notion of
covariant contravariant like things but
is that generalizable to triples of
indices and things like that the deity
of the algebraic interpretation would
not be that clean but the operation
itself yes and we have it with with
trace so you can do trace with three
levels for example do nothing at array
use a bigger ring yeah so I want to an
array of cap three for example at three
by three by three array exactly now do
trace of that what do I would add say
matrix trace no no trace dear OTO okay
TR of that array and I think you have to
say G comma 3 or + comma 3 you see it's
it's it's doing essentially in Einstein
Einstein convention it would be I mean
me me because I think by default it
traces as much as it can ok so the
alternative would be a level 2 trace
right which looks like that right so
it's stressing only through the first
two levels that's another thing you
cannot trace through levels 2 & 3 it has
to be the upper two so another natural
generalization in this function would be
having a list of which levels you want
to trace that makes sense I mean but
that's then a contraction I mean you
could represent that as a tensor
contraction correct so in other words
your your trace here is the analog if i
if i'm to do this except the tensor
contract doesn't have a g function it
just has plus if i would have that then
this would be a contraction of all three
of those levels is that right yes
I see so so that is the way in which we
generalize the summation convention to
allow ourselves to have a triple you
know triple matched indices right okay
all right so let's come back now to what
you're saying with array contract thread
well actually let's come back to
understanding this what is this thing
what is this operation you are
exchanging you're pushing a head down
what is that operation gosh it's not a
map operation what operations rearrange
the levels of an expression so in other
words if I say F of G of H of X what
operations do we have that rearrange
that to be an H of of F of whatever I
mean it feels a little bit like
commuting diagrams interesting claim I
would say the the idea is transpose it
just exposed was transporting list on
list but we could transpose other things
and that's the function I had above in
the code what they called it G not some
suppose a way so in addition to array
contract thread and by the way I want to
store this someplace is that the best we
can do all right let's call it what are
we gonna call this thread generalization
oh okay so what is this other thing
you're talking about here we're asking
what's the general idea of moving heads
up and down and I think I think it's a
transposition transposition of of the
levels but we don't have as you're
pointing out we don't have a the
transpose that we have merely rearranges
elements enlists it does not allow us to
transpose with things other than lists
as heads
yes but the functions you just evaluated
the code do you evaluate it a few couple
of sections ago was a general transpose
that does that okay half the bit fall
around and that code so that general
transpose takes an array of pinheads and
it will move tomorrow okay so if I were
to take this and I will say general
transpose of that and do now like 1 3 2
for example see it moved
hng yeah I understand and it will work
as long as things are rectangular right
and if they're not rectangular by the
way it could very well be useful to have
a version that that has missing element
insertion yes that's that's another
thing that's the rugged transpose do we
have such a thing no but it's it's easy
to implement that just a function used
for transposing don't applause all right
so right now transpose has two arguments
and the transpose that we have those
second arguments and 1 and 2 etc those
are the level specifications so if I
were to do this not very usefully but if
I were to say transpose and again I it's
not gonna be very useful in this case
something like this 1 3 2 although you
can't see it because they're all just
it's gonna be rearranging those lists
around right so why is it that we don't
make transpose work on heads other than
a list transpose comes from a rather
mathematical area in which people are
always thinking about lists and we could
make it work for this case we could but
of course it's one of those cases in
which we run into what's a scalar mean
it cannot be by default of course but
because now we have the allowed heads
the option we could play with that we
can have allowed heads as an option we
could have it as a third argument it's
an option already in transpose oh really
so if I say if I if I were to say
transpose of I would take this and I
would say allowed heads are a blank or
something allowed I mean it's not
implemented it's implemented for
Association and the first two levels
that's why it was introduced to support
transpositions of lists and associations
in other words okay but we could
perfectly well make this work - yeah
okay yeah
sander on the livestreams pointing out
the flattened consult handles some
ragged cases yes that's true flattening
is easier with respect to raggedness
because transpose actually requires I
mean what we would have to have is an
option here that says what would it be
set what would it be called it would be
something like a missing function or
something which I think we have don't we
have that no we don't have that we what
it really would should be is something
which is a thing which depends on the
index and says what to put in at that
position so it's given the synthesized
index what should be there and it could
just be it's always zero or something
which so zero Abbas and but it could be
that you actually do something that
depends on the on the destination index
the destination position that's true
that there is also the the approach in
injunctive laws which is that as long as
things are aligned to the left and to
the top the oppression is doable because
the result will also be aligned to the
left and to the top I salute you saying
so ragged to ragged works Brett in some
conditions I mean for example if you
have an empty an empty row when you
transpose it it will disappear things in
that yeah that's complicated but the
case handled by these junk table Lawson
and I think in the general in the
general case they are called Ferrer's
diagrams yeah that's that's justice okay
so that's an interesting thing for us to
do is to have some kind of ragged eyes
herbal transpose or maybe transpose
itself becomes ragged Aiza below k so
there are two cases for ragged there two
ragged cases some ragged arrays can be
transposed can meaningful be transposed
on their own
some require explicit insertion of
missing elements yes I think the
condition is as long as neck the
following row is not longer than the
previous room and the same for columns
this can be done uniquely sorry as long
as the water yes if you go down through
the rows they always they never have
they cannot be longer than the previous
ones I see makes some sense yeah um
let's see we got several comments here
one one comments on our live stream is
by Ray reshape and whether this can be
put as a generalization of a Ray reshape
that's an interesting idea
I think of every shape and belongs more
with flooding with a via of keep the
same elements but in a different shape
yeah you're right
however a ray reshape is also something
which could have missing element
handling that's yes oh actually it has
look right there it already has it
padding oh yes okay so that's worth us
remembering that array reshape already
has a that's actually a nice feature um
okay next point on a live stream comment
it would be nice to get a documented
version of normal at query of transpose
what the heck does that do what does
that do
that's a horrifying thing what is that I
think this is the idea of transposing
associations which is what we wanted to
achieve with transpose of a loud head
list Association so what's this thing
what's this crazy will creature that
just popped its head out so to speak
oh well this is the this is some sort of
compiled forms of the queries so for a
query you can do normal and it gets
transforming to something else that is
what internally oh boy that's this is a
kind of worms we should we should
discuss this at some future time this is
but but this particular operation this
association transpose operation we have
chosen for right now to make that into
the allowed heads operation so that
becomes this is effectively transpose of
hash comma allowed heads arrow something
what yes least commercially least least
commercial music these will allow heads
list and I think this works if you try
it with list of associations fair enough
I mean whether we want to repackage that
as an association transpose I'm not sure
we suggested a few times this I'm it's
been suggested enough times I think
maybe we should actually just do it
let's let's review that possibility okay
we actually have an association
transpose okay next a lively a question
can this be generalized to n god-shaped
data structures for example hexagonal
arise oh my gosh that is such a can of
worms we have been messing around with
those things for twenty years we would
love to just have a like like for
instance if we say rule plot of
something like cellular automata and
whatever
and then we say what is the what is the
option here for rule plot it is
guarantee be yeah that's right a year or
so appearance arrow hexagons okay look
at that and therein we start seeing the
trouble because where do you put that
second hexagon I mean that this is the
beginning of a slippery slope of horrors
that they're just many many many issues
with but I I mean we have wanted a
hexagonal or in general a lattice plot
for many years and I think we've
systematically failed to find meaningful
ways to deal with it like like for
example whatever the data is I don't
even know maybe merely just talk about
this for a second I mean whatever the
data is an axe ignore array it's not
representable by well maybe that's the
point that's being made on the live
stream it's not representable easily by
a rectangular list of lists what on
earth is it representable by is it a
graph of some kind what is it if the
graph form would certainly be
unambiguous I would think what would the
graph be so exact
it's a hexagonal it's a hexagonal
boundary array of hexagonal elements for
instance that would be one example of a
you know of a configuration right but
but what is because the other example is
a rectangular boundary of square
elements right so question is what is
the consistent boundary of a thing with
hexagonal elements and the problem is
you can't have I mean you you have to
have this weird business with even and
odd rows if you're having I mean this is
this is analogous to so another case of
this is bricks so that looks like that
another totally weird thing because
that's dealing with pears right am I
making sense I mean so it is an
interesting thing I'm I'm mum is there a
meaning to non rectangular arrays that
isn't totally what what is the
appropriate way to think about a non
rectangular array has this come up in
general lots of these settings Jose so a
tensor what would be the reason so a
tensor generally has see his where it
would come up right so yeah yeah yeah
okay so here let me ask you this
question so a normal tensor is a
Cartesian tensor its indices represent
lattice directions in Cartesian space
right okay what if you have a tensor
whose indices represent R Theta Phi in
spherical coordinates what is that well
in the end we are always mapping to
something rectangular so even when we
have this R Theta Phi we're still
thinking of the are axis the theta axis
and the y axis but we shouldn't be
because they're cyclic for example the
theta axis is no longer has the topology
of a Cartesian space
yes but the tensors don't leave in there
on the sphere itself they leave on the
tangent space and the tangent space is
infinite I see so your point is in in
the world of you know differential stuff
that you're always dealing only with the
tangent space which is by definition
cartesian for the tensors I mean you may
have the positions that the position
objects deal with coordinates and those
are cyclic but once you go to desks to
the 10 source then not you have
Jerell wasn't it in the tangent space
fair enough okay
I mean this has come up this business
about hexagonal grids has come up over
and over and over again and I don't even
know honestly I don't know you know so I
think in a lattice there clearly is a
way of doing positions in a lattice that
is the analog of you know positions
correspond to the you know given the
basis vectors in the lattice right isn't
it a feature of a lattice that to get to
any given cell on the lattice there's a
unique set of integers by which you
multiply the basis vectors to get to
that point in the lattice is that not
the definition basically I think so and
I think in crystallography that's right
in things like the Miller indices and
things like this um but go ahead I'm
thinking that in geography there are
representations of the earth based on
hexagons that become smaller and smaller
and smaller and there are some sort of
algorithms to name all these hexagons
like letters and numbers so this avoids
they all the problems we always have
with with participe and the poles
etcetera but it doesn't help why does it
help the hexagons so in other words your
tessellating the sphere with hexagons
which obviously doesn't work I mean it
no more works to test light with
hexagons from a squares does it well
it cannot be done exactly but but if you
just start with I mean it's same thing
we do with with sphere points I think or
they or the discretization of a sphere
there are some Pentagon's there
sometimes but most of the times is
hexagons based or tangles so you're
saying that there's a way of addressing
I mean it's like this crazy what three
words idea where you have you know where
you're where you know your front door
might be you know
elephant shoe chair or something right
yeah um that gets totally weird I mean
that's a basically a UUID for every
point right it's a very dog thing I
think I mean it can be generalized to
other shapes but what is the way of
thinking I'm sorry this is a bit of a
sidetrack but I'm just curious about it
I mean what is the way of thinking about
a lattice is there a way of thinking
about in terms of graph or what is the
way of or is it simply that the lattice
has you know the lattice and n
dimensions I see the real problem is
this the real problem is let's say
you've got a hexagonal lattice your
basis vectors are not orthogonal no
problem with that the difficulty is that
yes if it's an infinite lattice there's
no problem but if it's a finite lattice
understanding a container into which you
can put the thing you know because the
thing is going to be you know it can
have a hexagonal outer boundary or it
can have some wavy outer boundary it's
just very unclear what the you know what
what the limits on the indices look like
and things is that right and you'll have
weird things like that the that for for
even-numbered x-coordinates the
y-coordinate goes up to this and for odd
numbers it goes up to one different
which is really kind of weird and that
that is hard to represent in something
that is something like a list of lists
so I mean the the issue is we're mapping
to trees in okay let's try to understand
this why why do we have yeah the issue
is that well yeah I mean the thing I
just described doesn't in and of itself
cause trouble because we can represent I
mean in in some lower level you know
system we might not be able to do this
but we can perfectly represent a ragged
array where you know where we have you
know where it's like ABC you know a B
ABC we don't have any problem with a
thing like that I mean many of our
functions don't work that well on it but
but we can certainly represent that yeah
I mean we've had a number of summer
school projects on attempts to make kind
of lattice plot even lattice plot where
you I mean the quintessential case of
this and we're now seriously off topic
but I'll just show the quintessential
case of this um is let me show you this
um so in here
there is an example I think so if you
look at other geometries here we go so
this is this is for example these are 3d
geometries right so this is these are
what are they they Broadway lattices or
something um you know these have certain
unit cells right and then the question
is how do you represent how do you how
am i how am I saying this um am I making
any sense here I mean this is um the
problem is
the problem is how to map the values in
here into a grid that you can do
computations on because the neighbors
structure yeah yeah that's the issue
some of these have like 12 neighbors
right right so the course the the kepler
packing has 12 neighbors which is a what
is that that's a rhombic dodecahedron I
think um and so that could be
represented by a graph in which
everything has 12 neighbors yeah that's
the problem the problem is and we don't
have so the generalization of our
operations all the transposing and so on
we could generalize those we are working
on trees we could in principle
generalize those operations to graphs
but that's its own complicated story
does anybody know how this represent
okay Brett you made a comment about
commutative diagrams can you expound on
that how does this relate to the
category theory world no idea I mean I
was thinking my connection of
commutative diagrams was just sort of
you know the simple you know rectangle
where if you go down and over or you go
over and down right right but that but
that's where the whole generalization of
that is the whole story of category
theory and on those things and I don't
know does anybody on this meeting know
about that comment okay wrong wrong set
of people we have probably other people
who know but I've just recently I mean
the the whole world of category theory
which started off as kind of a wrapper
around algebraic geometry because it's
odd to sort of see how to transform
ideas from one area of algebraic
geometry to another you know got picked
up in more recent times in the type
theory business and in yet more recent
times in this in this sort of weird
convergence with Petri nets and with
quantum computing and with blockchain
stuff it's a very it's a very weird set
of convergences but really quite
interesting but I don't think I
understand it yet actually
zoo dark on our live streamis is
commenting that he's run into the
hexagonal array stuffing in
computational optics for unknown
isotropic materials and Sandra is
commenting the extension of Miller
indices is the Miller Bravo indexing
system used for X agonal lattices yeah
that that's right I mean the Miller
indices in general represent you know
those come out because people actually
see spots and x-ray crystallography
pictures and those can exist for any
that's the point though those are the
those are the Khazar the coefficients of
the basis vectors in reaching a given
point in the lattice alright so anyway
that's a separate discussion which would
be interesting to have some time is the
generalization is the whole lattice plot
story I really would like it if one day
we can actually I mean twenty years I've
been thinking about this lattice plot
thing and we just don't have a solution
to it um we should put that on our list
of things to look at I think it has been
on the on the ILD list for a while um
but let's come back to our our needs
here so the issue is we've got this this
operations that we've got your array
contract thread which is the
generalization of contract tensor
contract that is as you say the in so
far as I mean we have a chronica product
don't we which is a like an outer with
particular mathematical operations right
or tensor product right yes the product
reinecker product our variance of cota
right exactly what you're saying is that
tensor contract is to this new function
we're trying to create here
what well what for example dot is to NR
right yes that function you just
selected i think it's the most general
case of contraction and then we have
other sub cases and i'm suggesting one
more sub case which is this heads right
okay fine all right so first point is
the array contract thread idea which
seems like a good idea to have this
generalized function but now what is the
how does it specialize down the head
thread what what is the what's the
argument structure here that leads it to
be head thread it's special case of
choosing the third argument I would have
to think about it but it has the the F
and G freedoms are exactly the same and
then they're the list of arrays they are
would be the arguments of
of the initial function I feel and then
the third argument is something special
but I will have to think about it okay
right but it's a thing where instead of
you laying out the thing you're
operating on in a second argument it
lives inside the first argument so to
speak and this is kind of how to find
the pieces places that you want to do
things that exactly the difficult tasks
in using a reconstruct thread is how to
choose the third argument right you have
to choose the numbers carefully while
this new function is just a single
number that tells you the level you want
to come to go so it's not simpler all
right okay what are we gonna do with
okay let's talk about array contrived
thread
perhaps I can put it in in some other
context or had some documentation to it
for you just put it in the function
repository and just have it cool into
this internal function but also there
are a good reason why we can't just have
an array contract well it's not contract
is it I mean it's not really contraction
well I have another symbolical tensor
sorry contrast booties which is the
general case of a single array what is
it some sort of generalization of trace
okay but the word contract as you say
comes from I mean when you're using F
and G there's no contraction involved
nothing is contracting it's not it's not
squashing it is it so the F function is
the threading function and the G
function is the contracting function if
you know it's like a MapReduce so the F
function is mapping and the G function
is gonna is reducing isn't it right
exactly yeah so like any nerve it's
clear so f is is going through the
elements of the through pairs of
elements of the two arrays and then
pluses is summing is its reducing them
to some well yeah in the Stamper I'm
saying the word contract is hummus from
the idea that you are getting rid of
indices like contraction and a tensor
mew-mew just disappears for example um
but in this case you're not getting rid
of indices you're simply rearranging
things right it depends on the function
G so plus when G's plus is the function
that is doing the construction no I
understand okay so what you're saying is
the G if G is a function that scale
arises then you are removing tensor
layers exactly but if it is least for
example then John what or even just a
general symbolic thing you're probably
not accepted okay
um
I mean arguably just as outer you know
comes from notions of outer product I
don't know okay anyway the other thing
to name um
Oh Carla's just joined our livestream
and says he has many opinions about geo
position and well mostly we're talking
about how you take a single geo position
and turn it into individual points or
individual regions so if you have strong
opinions about that you should let them
be known if it's about different things
- it's your position let us know about
that - um okay but anyway back back - um
back to this so okay first question is
is the original operation we're talking
about a thread inside type operation is
thread inside a plausible name what is
that what is the description that we
would give to this function so we would
say do you have a proto documentation
for it I wrote something down
further down there threads the head
threads the head f but yes it still is
not relief not reading its thread if if
F has if the expression has multiple
arguments alright now let's talk about
how you know it's more like transpose
isn't it yes your generalized transpose
here how yeah that's very similar to
this function except for when the
function has to read right but threat
has the same situation thread can also
act like transpose yeah I understand I
mean if I if I say thread of that we'll
just transpose exactly alright so how
many functions do we have to name are we
also talking about your one argument
form of array contract thread or are we
not talking about that well I think this
to generate very general cases are
difficult and shouldn't be system
functions but this new thrilling I think
it should be a system function are you
sure this one shouldn't be a system
function well I'd be happy to have it a
system function but I'm not sure how the
previous time we discussed about it we
consider it worse to complicate it but
well we could have started off as a
function repository function as we just
discussed um I can try to create some
prototype segmentation I know we discuss
it fine I mean you could use that name
for the function repository but okay we
still haven't solved the problem of what
we're gonna do with this function
ah boy okay so there's a function that I
just don't believe in threads through n
levels I don't think that isn't I mean
so so Jose your proposed function can
pull the head up as well as down right
yep
should it be a threading function at all
or is it a head transpose function that
sounds crazy head transpose sounds
totally crazy
okay the minimal case takes F of
listless listless list X by actually
let's do the general case list list F
list list X and that turns it into and
that function head thread for example
can take it's basically deciding what
level now what's this gonna do this is
gonna have to say level let's say level
3 do it on F right but it's 3 done for F
so it's a relative change okay yes all
right why isn't this working
did I just not define it here Oh perhaps
yes I have called for that case ah ok ok
fine ok that was faked before right so
this is this case all right so this
would be F of listless listless list X
bar I don't actually need that effort at
the end there but this is now push it
down by two levels yes in this case
works
okay it's some kind of transposition
isn't it I mean if we think the second
argument is gonna be widely used yeah I
think so because otherwise too this
would be just threat so Jose would head
threat of that F of listless list X
comma infinity have meaning or does it
have to be a finite thing infinity I
would guess you to try to push F as deep
as possible through all lists right I
mean my real question is if the argument
to F was some sort of ragged depth list
thing is there a syntax that would
basically push F through whatever levels
of lists there are yeah I think until it
gets stuck you're saying I mean it's
never gonna be pushed through something
other than list or other right G yeah
for as long as as the fundamental rules
that is that if there are several
argument several arguments then they all
need to have the same head and the same
length they will go down as much as
possible
Sandra our live stream is pointing out
that in so far as it can both read and
unthread rethread is the possible name
I'm a bit unconvinced I think three
thread is very oh boy if I saw that on a
piece of code I wouldn't even know how
to read it
read it one might be like Ethelred or
something no I'm giving hard times a is
you're coming back to geo position
mm-hmm right now so if you have geo
position of list here comma list here
comma list here so that you have you
know one you know each time put another
level of lists around things
you're saying this case here and now put
the last two years inside of a list I
don't know what that does what does that
do okay now you want to say thread that
and who knows what that's gonna do
that's why okay so then you do you know
another thread you know possibly you
know at the second position and you get
a geo position you know lists geo
position list right yes geo positions
what's that you know the first details
yeah that was the disaster that threaded
right inside the geo position right with
the blind threading I didn't know what
it was threading right right yeah so in
that sense because you can control which
function is threading in this case your
position and through which this would be
more control but yeah I think you are
right that infinity suits thread as much
as possible an intake it would threat to
one level in the in one case button
Buster the other one we have a nice
whimsical suggestion on the live stream
of a head transplant by the time we have
a function called that if you see that
on a piece of it's like it's one of
those you are guaranteed not to
understand this piece of code you might
as well just start giving them your
names like Bob it's a it's a but okay so
look I think there's a meaning to
infinity but the main issue is what on
earth what is really going on in this
operation what is really going on we are
moving the thing up and down
we should push headbutt or pull head but
I think that's no less obscure than head
transplant honestly something involving
slide no way it's this metaphors are
incomprehensible to people I'm yeah you
know we get away with a few like sow and
reap we get away um yeah I mean comment
on the livestream about deep thread but
I think that the problem is any I mean
thread inside is okay let's let's think
about thread inside um the you know a
question on the live stream about tuple
negative level specs be supported yeah
because negative level strikes mean move
they'd they aren't negative level specs
they are actually negative head motion
that is you're moving the head up so in
this case here although this isn't
working yet - one would mean move that
head up I mean honestly it is sounding
more like a head transplant story
I mean it's moving heads up and down
what's the generalization I mean we
can't really talk about raise and lower
what is a you know the and yes the depth
thing there is a notion of you know at
what depth is f in here but that's I
mean the only way to ask that I think
how do we ask that we would ask position
of that and it's the length of that
right is the gives what depth F is at in
that in that expression I don't think we
have a function that says what depth
does something occur at there should be
a nice it's a service level I don't
think so because level level what level
will do is to tell you at a specific
level what's there right right
so it's inverse level yes I mean what
but that will be a nice at least
function repository function a thing
that finds the finds at what depth um
it's a very simple function to write at
what depth a particular thing occurs
instead of depth which is the depth of
the whole expression actually I'm now
curious whether I mean this is this is
basically a and at what Det whoops depth
um boy really this you know that would
be a two argument form of depth y them
know this is probably not general it's
not right because because they the thing
I'm no it's it's at what depth it's it's
like find a do a sounding so to speak
what what depth does this occur at as in
no that would be a different thing but
what I'm it is that sort of depth tells
you how deep you can go into the
expression in general oh I see to find
an arbitrary thing in it I see what
you're saying you're saying you're
saying do the depth if you said this
depth an expert of F depth an expert of
blank is the deepest that you can go
right that the depth depth gives you or
is the deepest level that you can go to
right right plus one this is saying what
is the deepest level at which F occurs
right
and in general one could ask for depths
plural of expo comer F which would be
the list of depths at which Africa's no
that's not totally let's at least think
about that as a generalization of depth
the deepest level at which F occurs and
this as the list of of depths are
certainly something I've needed a bunch
of times right I mean the question is
whether F is a literal or if it's a
pattern
I think it's obvious coordinate pattern
because otherwise the default case you
know the default case of depth is blank
right that that that's that gives you
the max which is equivalent to so then
ordinary depth you know of X bar is
equivalent to max of depths of X become
a blank right in retrospect given that
you have the pattern in count cases and
position that seems very natural it does
it does gosh how could we have not
noticed this for 30 years
um the yeah this is a good thing
I mean I've definitely needed this this
many times I'm just not really
internalized you know and I've ended up
with a position and then I've length the
position and so on and so on and so on
all right okay that's an isle the item
put it on the side let's and I have to
go in a moment here so um let's see we
got negative level specs I mean the case
of move F to the second deepest level I
switch a saying in other words in other
words I see what you're saying so you're
saying that so they're two different
meanings to minus two inside this thread
inside function or whatever it's called
one of them is push F up by two levels
and the other is make FB two levels from
the bottom because the normal meaning of
a negative level would be make F be too
low you know make F be two levels from
the bottom so I think the name if indeed
we're going to mean raise it up two
levels then I mean that's a new meaning
that we need a a name gosh can
distinguish with an arrow was a rule
from the second to the third or
something like that if you want to be
super specific that's possible except
that typically we don't want to know
typically we just want the relative yeah
I agree I mean
you could imagine that you can say
thread inside you know so a kind of a
bizarre thing would be thrown inside if
you're giving an F energy you could have
a blank and then you could be saying of
X bar comma and then you could say level
two to level four and then you could say
blank here because if you've given I
mean at least if it's a monadic function
I mean it's pretty it's a little obscure
okay we have a few suggestions on the
live stream here um okay someone's
pointing out Mathi is pointing out that
the cheer position if we had rethread of
gops or whatever this thing is called
thread inside of geo position comma - -
and the - - meant two levels from the
bottom then that would mean that that
would be the analog of the points sub
property of Geo position that is it
would always return a collection of
valid geo positions which are precisely
two levels from the bottom because that
geo positions of lists that's an
interesting point redistribute
reorganize restructure head reconstruct
head distributists tribute yeah
redistribute head head reorganize yeah I
mean the question is whether we want to
admit this is about heads I guess we do
I mean III think that say anything that
talks about heads has an additional
level of obscurity in my in my book you
know if we can avoid having to discuss
heads it's all the better
um we had a really hard time to reduce
them translating that into Spanish which
one Oh what was it I just started
curiosity not that I know Spanish but
what does it turn into what's what's the
in the end we used to carry Sarah which
is like them like the front part of the
bed or or the front part of the line of
the bus line or things of that it's the
beginning of something right but we
didn't wish to use --kavitha which is
the head of our formerly sudden that was
a bit strange no that makes sense I mean
that's like that's like I mean I wonder
what you know car and cutter so to speak
in Lisp what they you know yeah anyway
um okay we have not solved this naming
problem but I think we made a lot of
progress on this function oh dear okay
we'll have to come back to this again um
redistribute ahead is being suggested
yeah from level
yeah level from and - I mean it's heard
coming up with something you can go up
and down right I mean I keep thinking I
think of things like elevate or promote
or but does sort of imply a fixed
direction yeah which is wrong
yeah I mean look some of the losing
names that we've had are things like
through and operate which are head
operations that nobody understands
um I mean in the general theory of what
we were talking what we were calling
headdresses which is you know modifiers
on the head which we have some like
derivative as a model as a headdress um
but I mean I feel like by the way you
know in the generalization of functional
stuff headdresses are part of the future
but I think we have not um yeah too
obscure for now alright was a little bit
frustrating that we have managed to nail
a name down here but I think we'll have
to let this percolate and what did we
miss from the rest of this meeting this
was an attempt of discussing a few
functions that are still a litigates
and whether you think they could be now
converted into function repository from
Egyptian fraction definitely yes that's
an easy one
what is trim that I don't know histogram
Association what the heck is that it's a
version of system system list that
returns an association yeah it seems
okay to the others I'm not sure about
all right thanks very much and thanks to
lots of lots of good thoughts on the
live stream today thank you very much
guys and look forward to being with you
all again soon right
see you later